votre vidéo vous est présenté par
victoria tirer talents.com vous avez
plus de 5000 follower sur vos réseaux
sociaux
venez nous rejoindre et devenez
influenceurs grâce à victoria tirer
talents.com
da musica avec maintenant grichka avec
valérie benaïm voilà
allez venez regarder comme ils sont
beaux et juste à mettre vos pieds là
comme ça près de la ligne chacun de
votre côté on aurait été serait la liste
mais pour l'année le maire de man doit
s'amarrer de la lune près de la dîme
près de la ligne bien les pieds contre
la libye mais de là à la fin parce qu'il
est venu en après ce qui fait ses débuts
au haut niveau il faut pas bouger un
faux pas bougé pas ça prend les
attentions
ça prend les textes variés un là et de
temps qu'il le calcul tac ça va arriver
dans un instant là là on essaie de faire
une prouesse technique audi rénale c'est
quelque chose qui ne sera jamais refait
à la télévision française on la voit là
[Applaudissements]
mrm et b life ça ça et ça c'est pas mal
du tout séquestre excitante le gala
grichka benaid la valeri bojinov
séquelles mexique rennes alors je vous
explique
cet après midi nous avons demandé à
certains chroniqueurs de venir dans le
parking deux des huit pour tourner une
vidéo il ya des mathieux yahvé valérie
et yahvé erika sauf que nous les avons
piégés pendant le tournage
regardez leur action va démarrer par la
réaction d'erika moulet d'accord après
et on finira par valérie bénaïm parce
qu'elle est c'est quelque chose
erika moulet regardez c'est parti pour
être sûr de ne pas prendre la pluie
je compte sur toi tu entends bien oui
c'est bon ça va je traduis de bonus
[Musique]
je compte sur toi toi ça fait au [ __ ]
or il y avait eu peur en plus j'ai froid
et tout écouter la fois ci vous ferrez
coûte jusqu'à fin il y avait ce qu'il a
dit regardez ce qu'il a dit mais en plus
c'est froid et tout ça je l'aï dit quand
même ou pas mais vers la fin de la
balade aux de leur vaut pas d'un
baladeur et après on fera programme a
tué mokhtar ah oui mais c'est quoi cette
connerie bouger surtout pas bon je lai
chau
[Applaudissements]
morio attendait amd moctar ben moctar
faire beaucoup avec isabelle morini-bosc
willy bracciano away est sans rien mais
on peut faire ça jusqu'à 23 heures
je l'avais jamais bien les pieds devant
santé michaud ici merci d'echery sa
machine face à jade revient à tête ida
attention à l'isard la magie opère à la
magie opère attention la belge est en
fins palais ribes et naïve regarder
valérie bénaïm regardez moi pour être
sûr de ne pas prendre la pluie je compte
sur toi
[Applaudissements]
hier soir alors que super franchement
oui mais gore et grichka vous avez déjà
eu peur on vous sent pas avoir peur nous
en avoir peur de rien non jamais non
enfin définitive le matin de la glace
connaître
vous sortez tous et ont dit attendre
c'était de vol a eu ces tribus qui lui
[Rires]
qu'est ce qui se passe alors ne bougeait
pas les poches barbarossa demain ça ne
marche pas sur vous attendez alors c'est
bien avancée de la nuit
la tension est là et nous continuerons à
les y le menton pierre chaubon attention
a dit quoi dans l'oreille aller au débat
attendu là ça marche pas mal ça marche
pas